annika lass uns noch mal über die bilder
sprechen die uns erreicht haben eine
querdenker stürmte die bühne von armin
laschet nur durch einen ja nicht mal
irgendwie abgezogen keine
sicherheitskräfte greifen ein wie hat
dein armin laschet auf diese situation
reagiert
also amina steht hatte tatsächlich sehr
ruhig darauf reagiert wurde ja am ende
von karl lauterbach sogar dafür
kritisiert dass er den mann suhner hat
an sich rankommen lassen er hat aber gar
keine chance weil er hatte das mikro in
der hand hat in die eine richtung
geguckt und von der anderen seite kam
ihm diamanten stand plötzlich neben ihm
und hat ins mikro geprüft das heißt
armin laschet hatte gar keine andere
chance
weil er eben schon zu nah an ihm dran
war das problem lag also nicht bei armin
laschet sondern bei seinen
personenschutz und wie man es auch
wirklich gefragt wie konnte überhaupt
dieser mann so nah an den rand kommen
obwohl die personenschützer um die bühne
herum verteilt standen also das ist eher
der fragliche punkt weil normalerweise
wird er eigentlich sehr stark geschützt
und auch da waren viele da und man
konnte das erahnen dass da was passieren
würde
ja und da ist die verbindung war der
streit wir haben als vorher
also ich habe eben nur noch mal gesagt
also amila stadt hat sehr souverän
darauf reagiert und dieser mann stammt
eben schon auf seiner bühne
normalerweise steht der personenschutz
um ihn herum hier sehen wir es gerade
also er stand wirklich in dem moment vor
allem im land in eine andere richtung
geguckt hat stand da plötzlich neben ihm
und hat ins mikro gebrüllt also ihm
blieb gar nichts anderes übrig und dafür
hat er sehr souverän reagiert und dann
ja auch sehr ruhig mit ihm gesprochen
und den personenschutz dann auch weg
geschickt als er ankam lag er als ganz
herzlichen dank nochmal für diese
erläuterungen und wir sind jetzt mit
einem sicherheitsberater
verbunden wer uns die situation noch
einmal genau erklären kann und zwar ist
das malte rojinski
hallo herr jaschinski rojinski die
szenen die dort passiert sind der kern
sehen uns noch mal wie es dazu kommen
konnte und wo der fehler lag
die fehler sind hier ganz offenkundig
auf mehreren ebenen passiert das heißt
zum einen
ist es so dass normalerweise ja der
kanzlerkandidat begleitet wird von einem
kommando des bundeskriminalamtes von der
sicherungs gruppe
das wird in solchen übergangszeiten auch
gerne noch verstärkt von dem lka
kommando was er bisher hatte
was sie alles schief gegangen es ist das
in einer vor aufklärung da einfach nicht
gesehen wurde dass es hier keine
richtige sicherheitsabsperrungen gibt
sondern lediglich solche leitbilder wie
die sie aus wartebereichen in hotels
oder an flughäfen kennen die keinerlei
schutzfunktion haben das heißt die erste
ebene hier hätte sein müssen dass man
hier mit absperrgittern arbeitet die
aufstellen lässt so genannte hamburger
gitter sind dass das war sozusagen das
erste problem ja wir sehen die bilder
auch hier während sie sprechen was war
das zweite problem dann sehen wir
natürlich dass angesichts der fehlenden
der fehlenden umzäunung die dort quasi
nicht nicht vorhanden war hätte die
aufstellung der personenschützer hier
auch eine andere sein müssen das heißt
wir sehen jetzt gerade im bild von
rechts kommen die so ein bisschen rein
also aus dem hintergrund das große
problem ist hier dass diese bühne fast
kreisrund zugänglich war wie sie jetzt
in diesen bildern auch von hinten können
sozusagen oder konnten personen da sich
theoretisch annähern in so einem fall
müssen eigentlich zwei personenschützer
in nähe des rednerpults in der von herrn
laschheit positioniert sein damit sie
dann sehr schnell reagieren können und
eine derartige annäherung durch
irgendeine person egal ob das jetzt
jemand ist der mit blumenstrauß ankommt
oder der ein autogramm will oder der
irgendwas mikrofon sprechen will darf
niemals passieren in so einer phase
heraus gehen wie ist denn diese
situation jetzt ja auch historisch
einzuordnen wenn wir jetzt auch an die
attentate auf oskar lafontaine oder auch
wolfgang schäuble zurückblicken ganz
genau also das ist 30 jahre her
dass wir denken zum beispiel an das
attentat auf oskar lafontaine da ist
eine attentäterin adelheid streitel hieß
sie mit einem blumenstrauß in dem ein
messer versteckt war auf nach einer rede
auf oskar lafontaine zugekommen eine
ähnliche situation
er hat nichts böses geahnt und sie zog
dann das messer und hat ihm dann in den
hals gestochen oskar lafontaine hat nur
sehr knapp überlebt das ist ein
typisches beispiel dafür wir sehen dann
noch mal die bilder von dem attentat
damals da sind eigentlich die lehren
daraus gezogen worden und auch
normalerweise beim bäcker beim lka wird
sehr professionell gearbeitet
wird normalerweise durch voraus
kommandos auch aufgeklärt ob es
bestimmte schwachpunkte gibt an einem
veranstaltungsort und die werden dann
entsprechend auch normalerweise
beseitigt das ist also keine lappalie da
kann dramatische folgen kann so etwas
haben was wissen sie über die
personenschützer selbst die jetzt daran
beteiligt waren
interessant ist es ist jetzt nicht
bekannt ob das ein privat engagierte
sicherheitsdienst war den vielleicht die
cdu beispielsweise engagiert hat als
partei als auftraggeber oder das jetzt
personenschutz darf eines
landeskriminalamt und das bka war die
tragen normalerweise
kleine pins am revers und das war nicht
zu sehen hier in diesen bildern also das
deutet eher darauf hin dass es eben kein
politiker personenschutz war man sieht
auch zum teil an den haltungen von den
sicherheitsleuten jeder drum herum
stehen die sakkos hinzu zum teil so
sehen
da jetzt in diesem hintergrund gibt
personenschützer die das sakko zu haben
normalerweise müsste das aufstellen
damit die waffe da schnell gegriffen
werden kann die positionierung hinten
sehr zurückhaltend auch fast passiv sie
sehen es da im hintergrund das ist nicht
das was man in dieser situation erwartet
normalerweise muss hier an dieser stelle
wo jetzt hier dieser ich sag mal störer
sollte sich dort hervor gibt jemand in
der nähe sein der dem ja man kann es
sportlich sagen tackelt und wirklich zu
boden bringt denn diese annäherung darf
auf keinen fall stattfinden
warum diese aufstellung da in diesem
moment nicht professionell vorgenommen
wurde das muss sicherlich untersucht
werden und da muss man dann auch
entsprechend mit dem kommando reden was
dort aufgestellt war und für die
zukünftigen veranstaltung von herrn
laschet ganz klare konsequenzen ziehen
vielen dank herr jaschinski vielen dank
für die einordnung diese ausführliche
und anschaulicher einordnung
[Musik]